willkommen zu unserer welt oder
kinderwelt wissen heute in seinem
kinderzimmer und neben sami rassist alex
unser voller los berlin
wir hatten ihn schon mal zusammen eine
torte gebacken und heute haben wir uns
was ganz besonderes überlegt und zwar
möchten wir heute ein paar apps
vorstellen die für kinder geeignet sind
jetzt fragt ihr euch wie es vielleicht
wieso apps also alex hat ja einen
technik kanal mister helfersyndrom und
da stellte alle zehn tage apps fonds und
ich finde es immer super weil ich kenne
mich damit eigentlich 0 aus und schaut
immer mal bei ihm vorbei und da gibt es
auch wirklich sinnvolle sachen wir
hatten ja auch schon am video über
ernährungs oder apps über die ernährung
und über die gesundheit finde ich auch
richtig klasse und heute muss überlegt
ein paar apps für gehirn abläuft
erfindung ich sie dort mit links nur
beschreibung spox unter diesem video
genau und vielleicht fallen weg also ich
bin so eine mama ich bin nicht dafür
dass kinder oder ja so kleinere kinder
smartphones oder tablets bekommen aber
ich finde wir sind in so einer zeit da
muss man sich schon so ein bisschen
heranführen und ich finde ein bewusster
umgang damit ist eigentlich immer ganz
gut vor allem gut samira kennt sich
sowieso schon aus ich glaube die haben
das automatisch in die mit drin diesen
youtube und kann besser mit dem
smartphone umgehen als oma und opa aber
ich finde so ein bewusster umgang ist
ganz gut vor allem gibt es auch viele
apps die pädagogisch wertvoll sind oder
ein paar apps sollen sie gleich
vorstellen
ok dann legen einfach direkt los unser
erstes spiel behandelt ein thema das
viele kinder passiert und zwar dinos
ziel das spiel ist es dass man so hier
wird uns schon gesagt ich wünsche euch
erklärt deswegen höre mit sich die sonne
sorgt das was mir hier beide machen sie
mir was muss man machen hier
man muss die dinosaurier suchen
man geht also von rechts nach links
versucht den deal zu finden wenn man
findet man drückt man drauf und
fotografiert es gibt auch eine audio
anweisung die ihr sagt dann haben wir
wieder dinosaurier heißt es immer so ein
bisschen diese tiere kennen vielleicht
uns noch ein bier da sind ganz große
sehr gut ich bin das spiel ganz cool
weil die kinder einfach hören müssen und
hinhören müssen was eben die sonne sagt
und dann müssen sie diese anweisungen
befolgen und vor allem gibt's da eben
auch nicht nur dieses suchspiel also wo
sie nach rechts und links müssen sondern
man kann dann auch so ein puzzle draus
machen
genau wenn man jetzt alle gefunden hat
ich gehe mal raus ins fotoalbum würden
alle dinos fotografierte kann man ins
hauptmenü die app und ins fotoalbum und
dort kann man dann aus diesem system 1
aus aus den bildern ist klar
dann schüttelt man das handy und dann
wirft man schüttelt desto kleiner wird
das puzzle desto mehr teile bekommt das
puzzle und immer mit wirklich schwer
deswegen schütteln erstmal nicht zu lang
dann kam hier eben noch ein kleines
puzzle aus in diesem fall zwölf teilen
spielen sie mir ich hab mir sage okay
also dass die ersten versuche jetzt das
geld wieder zusammensetzen nettes
kleines team spielen
ist das vielleicht später fertig spielen
geschafft
weiter geht die nächste finde ich
richtig klasse die nennt sich nämlich
matte duell oder messe duell
und zwar geht es darum dass man seine
matte fähigkeit ein bisschen aufbessern
klang wir sind üben kann wir haben
gerade eben schon geübt deswegen lassen
wir es nicht richtig bekommen das thema
nochmal mit leichtem auto also auf jeden
fall kann man auswählen zwischen leicht
mittelschwer und experte und zwischen
den einzelnen aufgabentypen addition
subtraktion multiplikation und division
das heißt da können zum beispiel eltern
auch einstellen und sagen okay für
meinen erstklässler mache ich jetzt um
die addition leichte aufgaben für den
viertklässler mache ich jetzt noch
multiplikation mit rein oder division
mit rein und so kann man sich das eben
auswählen alex ich würde sagen wir
machen jetzt keine addition und
subtraktion sondern eine multiplikation
ist klingt okay und macht so okay es
geht darum mich aufgabe kommt ein punkt
haben sie falsch warum ein punkt
abgezogen um das erste szene hat gewinnt
nicht nur bis 5
wir mögen das spiel einfach weil ja ich
muss man so schön drücken so michael
drücken weil wenn der eine schon mal
richtig gedrückt hat kann der andere
über erklären kann er bekommen hier
findet dass man so spielerisch ein
bisschen seine matte fähigkeiten
trainieren kann und es macht kinder
wahrscheinlich mehr spanier alles
trocken zu rechnen sogar mit freund ein
bisschen spielerisch oder mal gegen papa
oder mama antreten
wir machen weiter mit dem spiel million
rasch minions sind ja die meisten kennen
einen begriff sein ihre was muss man in
dem spiel machen genau es ist ein
jump'n'run spiel sozusagen mit einer
kleinen story und ist imam laden fabrik
und so weiter und so fort aber es geht
mir gesagt darum zu laufen sie mir ich
geb dir gleich das handy und du rennst
durchs level wir dort mir drauf und dann
aufspielen
so jetzt lädt es hier gleich und dann
geht's ihnen daumen die gold münzen
einzusammeln und nicht gegen die
hindernisse zu düsen
ich sag provinzen erklärt mal dem alex
wieso bananen
ausweichen genau jetzt nach links
der puls sehr gut und springen ein
bisschen zur ist schade aber ich denke
versteht wie es geht ist ein lustiges
spaß wie gespielt und ich sie beim namen
sammeln und nicht die münzen
viele kinder sind ja keine großen fans
von zähneputzen sind ihre puts die gern
die zähne ok sehr gut wie mir ein
vorbildliches exemplar kind wir haben
eine app mit der das zähneputzen für
kinder ein bisschen mehr spaß macht und
zwar hat man hier ein cowboy und eine
frau sie mir mit wem wirst du die zähne
putzen
okay wir nehmen die fee trick auf
zeitpunkt und die p sprich doch mit
einem mann kann sich erklären lassen wie
man zähne putzt aber das weiß sie mir
schon als drittem auf dem blauen knopf
wo jetzt putzen steht jetzt geht es
darum dass man die ganzen monster die
mit einem und hat als die ganzen
bakterien rausbekommen also mir kurz mal
kräftig muster kräftig kräftig schrubben
damit ihnen die monster aus dem mund
verschwinden jetzt sind sie weg und dann
zeigt die app an an welcher stelle man
als nächstes putzen soll jetzt gibt es
also auch die andere seite da die
monster weg machen
das wirklich spannende ist dass die app
mit der kamera schaut ob das kind auch
wirklich putzt wenn jetzt sanieren würde
mir zähne putzen dann würde ich etwas
mehr und sagen hey muss auch die monster
weiter bekämpfen sie mir erst mal nicht
kurz mal nicht sondern jetzt schauen wir
mal ob die apps ist mehr weil du musst
besser putzen sagt sie aufgehört das
jetzt schrieb chop chop chop chop
schritt werden und diese daten nur
verwendet dass man hier dem kind sagt es
soll weiter wachsen also nicht so ein
bisschen motiviert zu putzen die monster
zu beseitigen und nach ein bisschen spaß
oder die letzte app kennt zum ihre
bereits und zwar ist es die kräfte hat
samira so ein virtuelles haustier und
kann das füttern muss es pflegen damit
gesund bleibt muss aktivitäten damit
machen also spielen damit spaß hat und
ist hier muss ich auch aus muss ich
tatsächlich auch sonst kann zum beispiel
kein sport hier machen die app so
gefüttert ist es gut es ist absolut voll
und so doch immer dicker während dem
dreh hier sagen mal dass wir spieler die
man oft spiele hier raus dachte was
spiele sehr gut okay hier geht es darum
dass man das traurige gut hier finden
mussten drücken damit glücklich so mal
wurde das traurige ist wer schaut
traurig
der monster unter der schutzraum genau
da habe die mundwinkel nach unten sind
immer der mitte hat ganz viele
verschiedene skandal zum spielen ein
bisschen langsamer schon mal das traurig
da oben sehr gut und so viel ich mit
viel spiel 20 zur auswahl oder so und
sehr kleinen zeit betreibt ist
abwechslungsreich und man kann eben hier
so ein bisschen verantworten gang
während ohne ein echtes tier haben zu
wissen denn ich möchte kein echtes tier
zu hause
das waren jetzt fünf apps die wir uns
ausgesucht haben ihr könnt uns ja mal
einfach in die kommentare schreiben
welche davon euch am besten gefallen hat
mir was ist deine lieblings apps am putz
oder auch alle an
ok meine lieblings etwa auf jeden fall
die matte oder wollte spaß gemacht
murat jetzt demnächst auch wieder machen
ja auf jeden fall könnt ihr uns auch
gerne schreiben falls ihr noch andere
apps für kinder kennt welche toll sind
dann schaue ich die mini mir nehme ich
auch mal ganz genau und alex vielen dank
für deine unterstützung sehr gerne zum
spaß gemacht sehr gern richtig coolen am
alex und wenn ihr die apps über
ernährung und gesundheit noch anschauen
wollt verlinken wir euch das video in
der infobox auf alex kanal bei mister
helfersyndrom super bis zur nächsten mal